hi this is Rufus Wainwright and doing
the TED talks here and this is a song
that I wrote called peaceful afternoon
it's on my new album coming out July
10th called unfollow the rules and I
wrote it for my husband yarn and it's a
love song and about how wonderful this
world is so here we go
[Music]
well it's coming on to the teen years
together
I pray that it's a luck a lucky lucky
number
and although
I've brought you Joe
happiness bed I've also been a food
becomes resourceful
a part of the game get the part of this
is
[Music]
and I pray that your faith is the last
nurses
useful
and now that our machine
running at full steam I pray the nothing
shucks wrenches to the man
but remember ever after
a part of the game
[Music]
a part of this is
and I pray that your faith is the last
piece
[Music]
the part of the game the part of the
cell
[Music]
and I pray that your pain fit the less
that's
ah
[Music]
is
and just in case you go before me rest
assured that second
let my face then my face is the last
you'll sit
is
[Music]
this is a song I wrote called going to a
town I'm going to town as I'm Annabelle
I'm going to a place that has already
been discreet I'm gonna see some folks
who ever
let down I'm so tired
[Music]
I'm gonna make it up for all of the
Sunday Times I'm gonna make it up for
all
then
it seemed to want to tell the truth I'm
so tired of you America making my own
we're home ain't gonna be alone I got a
love
I got love
tell me
do you really think you got
for heaven love not for thinking
everything that you've done is good I
really need to know what is soaked in
the body of Jesus Christ and blood I'm
so tired
[Music]
I really need to know why Magister see
you again
[Music]
you took advantage of a world that loved
you well
I'm going to town
[Music]
I'm so tired
making my own
we're home ain't gonna burn alone
I got a love
f2
I can love
I got so
I gotta true
[Music]
Oh
who
they go
ah
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]